you know there's a lot of advice out
there on youtube so today we're gonna
process through some of the dumbest
advice ever given by successful people
[Music]
okay so let's get right into it point
number one you have all the time in the
world don't worry you're young you don't
need to have so much urgency but in
reality i've never met anybody that one
at the highest level with constantly
trying to take their time thinking of
all the time in the world can you
imagine let's just have three o'clock
appointment to have a job interview and
you say your uncle says johnny just
watch one more quarter you have all the
time in the world don't worry about it
your homework's due tomorrow let's just
say you got the finals and your brother
says dude just let's play one more hour
of this video again don't worry you have
plenty of time the whole idea of you of
all the time in the world tend to get
everybody else to get calmer and what
i've found that when people say things
like that to me they're the ones that
are the most urgent they just want me to
kind of slow down so i can't catch up to
them it's a very strange way of
competitors trying to get you to slow
down okay point number two is going to
confuse you because it's the complete
opposite of point number one which is
what you don't have any time let's go
you got to get going you're getting
older which in reality that's my message
i'm an urgent guy i'm a guy that's like
let's go let's go let's go but that
message to a 45 year old 50 year old who
just went through a divorce
who may be sitting around thinking this
is it for me life is over with i can't
do nothing about my life right now
that's also wrong because for you you
have to realize that in your mid 40s or
50s in today's time we're living a long
time the whole purpose of urgency to me
is don't take your time to figure out
whatever the solution may be to the
current challenge you're facing that's
the issue you may be 45 years old right
now you may be saying but pat i feel
like it is too late for me what may be
too late for you is the last 25 years
you always thought you have a lot of
time in your life like i got plenty of
time tonight now that you're 45 knowing
you don't have a lot of time you got 20
more years to 65. maybe you got to kind
of get going but at the same time don't
get discouraged to think there's nothing
i can do my life right now because i'm
45 years old you still have time point
number three which is sleep on it just
take your time sleep on it here's what
i've learned with that advice
eighty percent of the time fine it works
the twenty percent of the time if you
sleep on it here's what could happen to
let me kind of give you an example
clients unhappy okay let me just have
them sleep on it i'll call them tomorrow
while you're sleeping on it another guy
or gal called got the business the next
day they're never gonna answer phone
calls ever again so for me i prefer the
now mentality i call the client
and i say johnny i heard you're upset
tell me what happened that made you
upset well let me tell you what happened
15 minutes they go off at me
great
i am so sorry about your experience tell
me what i can do to make it good because
i want to be able to keep your business
what can i do to make it good well
patrick uh
here's what you could do
great if i can get that for you can we
move forward and let us earn your
business again okay but can we move over
doing business together you know what
patrick the fact that you called me and
you heard me as upset as i was i
respected so much because i was about to
go to the other competitor's side and i
was about to change my business and go
do it with them literally i'm on my way
to their office
i can't tell you how many times i've
been told that just because i called
them right there they told me i was
about to leave you to somebody else or
an issue a problem say hey like oh my
gosh you won't even believe what's going
on in this office
catastrophic what's going on this office
let me just sleep on it and i'll call
him tomorrow
then i call him that night hey what's
going on oh pat you don't even know what
just took place what happened so we just
got robbed there's a guy that's over
here that's what's gonna you gotta be
kidding me no not at all okay have you
called anybody you know let me let me
call somebody else this person comes in
next thing you know the issue gets
resolved if we would have waited would
it cost me a hundred thousand dollars if
i tell you 50 times this has happened to
me i'd be giving you a small number so
the whole purpose of sleep on it
i get it if you're about to make a big
long-term decision i think i'm done with
my marriage i'm going to get a divorce
maybe you ought to sleep on it right
i'm done with this thing i'm going to go
out there and send my letter resignation
maybe you ought to sleep on it but some
of the other stuff do not sleep on it
call right now get that issue resolved
right now before you lose that business
or that opportunity dumb advice number
four listen just keep trying don't worry
about it it's all right just keep trying
eventually it's gonna work out for you
wrong advice because if i keep doing
something the wrong way over and over
and over again i'm still gonna get bad
results if you tend to have bad
relationships one two three four five
six and you keep doing the same things
there's something wrong with your habit
or your trend so you don't just keep
trying you take a step back you try to
go study the approach and you ask
somebody else what they think about your
approach that they're getting results
you try to study it and then maybe you
keep adjusting and making pivots and
then you try a new way so maybe it ought
to be just keep trying new ways until
you get the results rather than just
keep trying okay so point number five's
got two elements to it one is we're all
equal you don't have to worry about we
are all equal or you treat everybody
equally both of them are wrong here's
why number one we're not all equal when
i first came up in sales and i'm
competing against the other guys
the other guy was not equal with me when
it comes down to skill set he's here i'm
here the other guy is not equal when it
comes down to strategies he's here i'm
here the other guy and i competing we're
not equal he has a refund database of
500 clients he sold memberships to i got
zero the only place that we can be
equaling is what work ethic it's the
only place the only place we can be
equal in is who's improving faster today
that's the only level playing field not
expertise not database not market not
skill set we are not equal in that area
right now here's the other part in an
environment where it's like we treat
everybody here equally that's not the
right way to build a company if i have
somebody that has more expertise paying
bigger price has been around longer who
knows the culture that person is going
to have an upper hand over somebody that
does not by the way if somebody comes
and let's just say this person has been
around for 10 years knows the culture
more has good skill set but say we bring
a c-suite executive
that has been in the industry three
times longer than this person okay has
led a team of 400 employees okay in
areas of leadership this person is not
going to be treated the same as this
person this person is going to get more
uh recognition in areas of expertise and
areas of the experience they bring to
the industry they went but in areas of
culture the company this one's ahead
when it comes to culture this person can
sit there and say listen here's how the
company's culture is this is what we do
this is what we do great and that person
can say well some of these things we
need to kind of improve and some of
these things i understand i understand
what the culture is right that's the
concept to be cool no not everybody is
equal at a company and you shouldn't be
treating everybody equally in the
company fairly yes equally no
point number six just be positive it's
all gonna work out you know it's life
it's just about positive if you sit
there and you think about positive
thoughts someone's gonna knock on your
door with a million dollar sale and your
life's gonna change if you think
positive thoughts and sit around after
you apply for 10 jobs someone's going to
call you and they're going to offer you
the job because you're thinking positive
now here's what i'm gonna tell you i'm a
big advocate of positive thinkers
there's something unique about working
around somebody that's got positive
vibes positive energy versus a negative
one but i've met a lot of positive broke
people because they don't have any skill
sets they offer you eventually have to
bring value to an organization outside
of just being positive if you're
positive and you know how to sell your
value is higher if you're positive
you're a worker and you know how to sell
but if you're positive you have a
specialized skill set to edit you have a
specialized skill set on how to code you
have a specialized skill set because
you're positive and you have a skill set
obviously your market value goes higher
so buy itself positivity you need a
little bit more than that to invest in
business it's good to be a friend with
someone that's positive but the business
world wants you to be positive and an
expert to bring value to the table
point number seven is the whole concept
of you need money to make money right
just think about the idea you need money
to make money i've said this before it's
a form of a cop-out because if you say
you need money to make money is the only
thing you can offer to the market is the
money in your pocket which the reality
of it is
i have other things to offer to the
market instead of money i can offer my
contacts i can offer my expertise i can
offer my relationships i can offer my
work ethic that i can also exchange for
money if i give you results to your
company i get money in exchange now of
course
eventually you're gonna need money to
invest into a company all the other
things you need to do start a business i
totally get it but as far as the same
goes you need money to make money
there's many different ways people
exchange for money and most of it
doesn't have to do with money if a
person goes to a company making a
hundred thousand dollars your fifty
thousand dollars you half a million
dollars you do they go in and say you
know what
before i give you two hundred thousand
all your salary i need you to give me a
hundred thousand dollars is that kind of
what happens then what happens they
didn't give them money to get money
right no it's skills time effort
specialized skill set that'll also get
you the money then if you want to start
your business yes you do need to kind of
figure out a way to go raise money
number eight says raise as much money as
you can who cares give up that equity go
raise it if you can raise 10 million do
it 50 million do it
this concept may make sense in silicon
valley because most people start with an
idea a team so they say okay i want to
go raise 50 million bucks i get it if
for anybody else that's running a
regular business that's maybe not in the
tech world you don't necessarily have to
go try to raise as much money as
possible here's why so what if i go
raise too much money and i go from you
know a 80 majority to all of a sudden a
49 majority now the board keeps telling
me what to do and i'm no longer a
founder i'm going back to having the
same exact position i had somebody's
telling me constantly what to do i don't
want to give up that much control so
maybe the answer when we raise as much
money would i given up control fine i'll
buy that or
take your time raise a little bit of
money grow your business save the equity
so the next year when you go out and
raise money the company's worth 50
million dollars now you're not having to
give up 50 maybe you only sell that
percentage for 10 5 15 you keep more
equity for yourself and the business is
proven you're not going out there being
desperate to want to raise the money so
yes it does make sense not in all cases
point number nine is the famous the one
that everybody talks about you should
live a balanced life
we don't
live to work
we work to live right hey this whole
thing is about enjoying your life fine
i'm with it i don't know a lot of people
that enjoy having fun in life as much as
i do when i qualify for company trips
when i would go all over the world
there's only one place you would find me
i'm not the guy that stayed at the hotel
i'm jumping off a cliff i'm out there
swimming with sharks i'm out there
swimming with dolphins i'm trying
something new because i want to live my
life that's what i do one time we went
to an event in hawaii
and we have 100 something people there i
decided to go out there because i wanted
to walk by the volcanoes because the
volcanoes the lava that the volcano was
active and the lava was coming i've
never seen active lava before i went to
lava right in front of me just to see it
it was crazy but i loved it so i like to
live my life however
this will balance life thing if you ever
want to do anything big in your life
there's going to be phases in your life
where it makes zero sense if you're in
sports and you're running for a
championship you don't have a balanced
life if you're making a massive movie
that could potentially win an oscorn
academy you're not living a balanced
life if you're deciding to have a kid
we've gone through four of them i can
guarantee you my sleep life right now it
ain't balanced there's nothing balanced
about having kids don't let anybody fool
you nothing about having kids balance
life so but having a kid are you kidding
me it's an incredible feeling when my
kids run up to me priceless when you see
a project and then you look at it and it
does very well and people appreciate it
you sit back and the guys we really
crush we work very hard we have 16 hour
days we crushed it we did it together
nothing about it was balanced so yes
parts of it fine but if you want to do
something that you're proud of that for
the rest of your life you can talk about
and laugh about it and think about it
and reminisce about life's gonna be
unbalanced during those times point
number ten you've heard this one before
the whole just be yourself why are you
trying to please other people just be
yourself and everything's gonna work
itself out okay let's break this one
down
when you're at the house no one's around
when you're just being yourself on the
couch how are you sitting where are your
hands what are you eating what are your
clothes look like what do you look like
in your room when you're just being
yourself can you imagine if you went to
a japanese just being yourself actually
think about that right
i dress like this today because now i've
had success in my life but when i first
started working on morgan stanley dean
would have a 21 22 year old going
knocking on doors of people with money
to try to earn their business this look
doesn't work it just doesn't work i had
to be suited up i had to wear a nice
suit with a nice tie and be presentable
and go
speak to them and carry myself in a
certain way that maybe i wouldn't carry
myself around my friends while we're
playing billiards because if i talk to
the client the way i talk to my guys in
the army
the chances of these people doing
business with you are probably slim
again
later on when you win do whatever you
want to do people going to say i respect
this guy but at the beginning when it
comes on to business and sales first
impression matters a ton and if you're
being yourself like the way you're
around your friends and family in the
first impression it's probably going to
hurt your chance of closing business or
getting that job or whatever it is you
want to do
if you're just being a little bit too
much of yourself without presenting
yourself in a professional way okay so
if any of this have helped you out give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel i got two other ones for you but
they're so deep i can't explain it in
this video one of them is this whole
concept about following your passion if
you're not seeing the way i explain it
click over here and the other one is the
myth of multiple streams of income what
a waste of an advice given to millions
of people who actually buy it if you
have not seen it click over here to
watch it take care everybody bye
[Music]